i'm on a much different scale brand new
fallout and britney spears years-long
legal drama
to break free of her conservatorship
support pouring in for the pop star
after
dramatic testimony where she detailed
what she called abuse of conservatorship
and severe mistreatment by her own dad
spears telling the court she had no
control over her life
or her finances making other explosive
claims like how she was forced into
involuntary medical evaluations and
rehab
and she was made to take medication
against her will spears is also saying
quote
i was to be able i want to be able to
get married have a baby i was told right
now under the conservatorship i am not
able to get married
or have a baby katie it is absolutely
infuriating to me that
they even made her have an iud that
she can't even control her own
reproductive uh you know rights it's uh
it's
outrageous yeah they're forcing her to
be on birth control and then my
follow-up question to that is well if
she were to get pregnant would they then
force her to have an abortion since
they're controlling the rest of her life
conservative ships are supposed to be
about taking care of somebody who can't
take care of themselves they're supposed
to
be so that you can help someone live a
happy life because they're not in a
position where they can
take care of themselves in a proper
careful way this is not
that i mean her testimony about what
they have done to her she likened it to
being
sex trafficked and being stuck as a
prisoner inside her own
home they're clearly not taking care of
her in a way that has anything to do
with loving her
or wanting her to live the best life
that they can to help her through
and when it comes to what the judge is
going to say we'll have to see it know
the rules and the laws for
conservatorships are basically
impossible to get out of
and when i watched the documentary
framing britney spears one thing that
stood out to me is they
did they said she wasn't competent
enough to hire her own lawyer
but then they allowed her to be
competent enough to sign her entire life
away for the rest of her life as a young
woman
into this lifelong conservatorship so
everything that we've seen so far just
doesn't add up in terms of being ethical
or moral or
based in any kind of ability to treat
her fairly
admittedly jesse i don't know everything
but it does seem well
done wait a second come on about
brittany
okay but i i do know that her father
seems like a skunk
he seems like a greedy you know
self-serving
how dare he she's almost 40 years old
she's had a career she's generated tens
of millions of dollars
entertained hundreds of millions of
people and here she is she's basically
a slave to a conservatorship uh that as
kd indicated has no bounds
i spoke to a britney insider today
geraldo who said
because he'd spent some time with her
during this conservatorship not johnny
not gonna name his name but he said that
the father before all this was just a
cook
and didn't make a lot of money wasn't a
sophisticated guy and the next thing you
know
he's now managing a multi-million dollar
empire of his daughter
and it's been 13 years and he doesn't
want to give it up and they have a
system set up where now
there is a team of lawyers for him
there's a team of lawyers for her
she pays both teams of lawyers and her
lawyers are corn appointed lawyers
so they didn't have a lot of money to
begin with now they're getting
loads of money from brittany they're
going to prolong this because they've
hit the jackpot
and it's a catch-22 so if they say
you know what we're going to send you
for an evaluation every single day
and she says no i'm fine i don't want to
do that
she's now said she's uncooperative
and then if she goes and talks to the
people of the therapy session
says i'm angry says i'm depressed well
then she's angry and depressed and she
needs to stay in the conservatorship
if you are incapacitated you do this to
someone
but she's not incapacitated she's
putting on shows she's hosting shows
she's actually paying the salaries of a
multitude of people
all she wants to do is have a regular
life with a kid and a husband and
they're not letting her do that they're
making her work like an animal
for their own financial interests
there's always dana two sides to a story
but it really feels like the weight of
the evidence supports this young lady
and her challenge to have her freedom
back i mean
it offends everybody as i understand
that conservatorship was just supposed
to help her get from
through a tough period it wasn't meant
to be a life sentence
but that seems to be like what she's
going through however the
father's lawyer says at any point
brittany is free to file a petition to
end the conservatorship and she's
actually never done that
i don't that's the part i don't
understand and i don't know anything
or everything well i did speak to my
insider okay about that and at one point
britney did get an attorney from the
outside because she did want to
file a suit and it brings the attorney
into the court and the judge says no no
no no
you can't use that attorney you can only
use the attorney that's been appointed
and the lawyer also told her never told
her that she had the ability to
get out of it aren't we right to care
greg i suppose so
i mean i didn't contact anybody on the
story right i'm not going to pretend to
be an
expert in five minutes on law but i will
say that
behind every family tragedy is a team of
lawyers perpetuating it
whether it's a contentious family
divorce and i'm a lawyer yeah i mean
like
like family law is probably one of the
most torturous
uh uh mazes of hell anybody could go
through and i only know that
from talking to people who've gone
through divorces and and where their law
there's no incentive all of this stuff
is based on incentives there's no
incentives
for lawyers to end this and you got to
wonder at this point who else could be
judged incapacitated
for a year or two i mean i i don't want
my wife to get any ideas
because i mean i've said some pretty
crazy things on this show and
you know my tweets are a little
disturbing she could probably find
enough but this is an industry
that doesn't care about you as long as
you're making them money she does two
shows
two shows a day for five years in vegas
that's gutfeld's schedule
right the problem is the worst
occupation in the world probably
more dangerous than being a lager is
child
star if you went through the numbers of
all the child stars and figured out
which ones were dead and which ones are
permanently damaged
it's probably a lot worse than people
who are longshoremen or loggers
which have 111 deaths for 100 000.
that's good to know in case you were
asking but this entertainment industry
is codified child abuse
they don't care nobody can i wonder if
i'm just
wondering if there was a female judge
would she have been more sympathetic
than these creepy old men who are so as
you indicate self-serving
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else